how to build an audience when most of
your keywords have heavy competition I
love the gym with you guys and help you
come up with the next videos to make
because I think a lot of people struggle
with what do I make next and I'm making
videos and nobody's seeing them and I
don't know what topics to work on this
is one of the techniques that I often
teach and we've gone through it before
but I'd like to customize it and get
some examples from you guys to make it
more personal for Zane's a confidence
coach so he's going to come here and
look at how to have confidence if that's
maybe a video title that he would come
up with and so we use a video IQ plugin
we've mentioned this it allows you to
see how many subscribers each channel
has and so this one you know eight
million views that's cool but it has 16
million subscribers on the channel so
it's an underperforming video so we
looked at this one how to be confident
in any situation it's got 13 million
views and 5 million subscribers so this
is one of the most popular videos on his
channel it's helping him grow the
channel and anytime we have a higher sub
count compared to the Views most videos
were on the perform their sub count so
most videos we'll get if he's got five
million Subs will get less than 5
million views whenever one does really
well that means it's a really good video
so we want to be taking on this video so
then I asked Stan in the office hey
saying can you make this video how to be
confident anything he's like yes perfect
go make that video and what what we'll
often find is the title that we we think
of is not the title that we end up going
with
right we started with how to have
confidence
and we end up with how to be confident
in any situation
right and then part two is this is to go
look at their Channel and then see what
their other videos are and if we sort by
their most popular ones
you can see you know to how to have
confidence one
that's here oh or did he do it twice no
it's here it's weird it's how to radiate
confidence under pressure
it's weird that it's showing up in
search is something different than on
his channel he must be doing a split
test
anyway this is the video and this is
number three video
so then you can look at what other
videos have gotten more than five
million views and there's not that many
you know he's got 5.3 million subs and
this is what 6 12 you know 15 16 videos
have more than 5.3 million views
out of all the videos that he's done on
his channel right like this will just
keep scrolling and these are still
decent videos right but they're not the
ones that are really growing his channel
so then you just look at all these and I
you know five five common habits that
make people instantly dislike you can
Zane do that video maybe maybe not you
know liking you is it tied to confidence
sure but it may not be in his wheelhouse
how to how to avoid embarrassing
yourself in an argument maybe you know
the Zayn talk about
arguments and negotiation embarrassment
you know it's it's on the verge
um but then something like this how to
turn awkwardness into confidence right
and then I asked and Zen can you make
that video it's like yes
like cool right and so you're just
basically looking for the videos that
are helping these videos are helping
grow
Chris Brown commands Channel
and even though it's you know it's
Charisma command not confidence on
command but there's a lot of confidence
related videos
so the one of the biggest shifts I was
trying to get people to make at the
conference was the game is not searched
the game is suggested because so many of
the experts teach search but most of the
views don't happen in search most of the
views happen What YouTube recommends you
so the goal is to rank after other
people's videos so the SEO game is how
do I show up after other people's videos
not how do I show up for that search
term and so
to the topic of how to build an audience
when your keywords of heavy competition
it's not so much about the keywords
having heavy competition it's any videos
that are doing really well awesome we
want to be trying to rank after them
so for for you guys are here are there
any topics themes that you want to
either pop in the chat or you know since
an intimate group you can unmike and
just we could Workshop it because I'd
love to be able to get
you leaving here with specific videos
you can go home and make
leadership skills
cool
so leadership skills is a really broad
topic right cool so that's a good
starting point so if we're here we're on
leadership skills
what do we got four tips improve
leadership skills with Brian Tracy
decent you know 649 versus 1.3 it's okay
10 leadership skills every leader should
have it's okay
1.6 versus 34. it's okay here's
something but Tony Robbins on the
psychology and skills of exceptional
leaders probably not one that you're
going to make unless you're going to
dissect Tony Robbins but not as good
this is actually this is actually rough
a lot of these are rough so far
here's one though how to be a great
leader the seven great leadership traits
1.3 million views off of 70 subscribers
or 70 000 subscribers
could you come up with seven great
leadership traits Terry
absolutely yeah so this is this is this
is a good one to make but overall this
is it also shows you how
how difficult it might be or how good a
topic is right so these people all have
a lot of subscribers actually this one
this one doesn't with the 1000 but a lot
of these videos they're getting a lot
fewer views and subscribers so it could
also lead us to think what else could we
call it instead of calling it leadership
skills what else could we call it
and by changing up one of those words we
might find a better topic so this is
this is this is a little bit below
average as a as a as a term but there
are still some gems in here you know
like this one how to be a great leader
seven great leadership trade this is the
best one on here
um
all of these are underperforming
unless it's specific right so Seth God
and even here garyvee talking leadership
skills 46 000 views but he's got 3
million subscribers
five crucial tips on leadership for
first-time managers
is that is that in the Wheelhouse Terry
or is that that's a good one I mean
because five crucial uh tips on
leadership for first-time managers I
mean the number one thing would be
developmental counseling
so I mean I have ideas in which I can
talk about on that
it's more does this so I mean cry five
if it was just five crucial leadership
five crucial tips on leadership cool but
for first time managers does that fit
into who you're trying to reach
it could I mean once again it's it's a
matter of of who I want to reach and and
if I'm wanting to reach first-time
managers yeah it'd be a good one
cool so this video really performed well
for him 18 000 Subs 238 000 views and
especially if you're a smaller Channel
looking at smaller channels right can
really help so
18 000 is not is not a it's not a tiny
Channel but it's not a giant Channel
either if we're looking at a Charisma
command it's got five million
subscribers
um so that's interesting body language
of leaders
is interesting I don't know if you go
that route or not Terry but I have I've
talked about things like for example how
the eyebrows is the most expressive body
part so I I do talk about some elements
of body language
so this is where it could get really
cool it's like hey you look at Vanessa
Fernandez this is the she's shown up a
couple times now right there's this
video but then there was this video
underneath
so this got 2.1 this got 360
000. I believe she was up higher
somewhere here
here 338 000. so when she's just talking
about leadership skills it's really
underperforming compared to talking
about the body language of leaders
yeah and this is what she's known for
but it's also you know it's what people
are searching for what they're
connecting with which is getting a lot
of traction on so could you provide your
perspective on the body language of
leaders and the goal becomes let's try
to show up after Vanessa van Edwards oh
yeah I probably have about seven to ten
things of body language I could talk
about for sure
cool and so that's that's the starting
point right so we've we've we've got
one video here second video here and
there was a third video
on this one right so these are so we've
got three video ideas that you can make
cool next is to look at all their
channels and see what other videos
they've got and if there's any fit
before even moving away so like already
leadership skills may not be the best
the best uh term because a lot of these
are underperforming so we can try on
another term that might give us a lot
more fruit but we've already got three
videos that we can use
right uh okay so next we go and look at
those channels you know
learning read the find was one what was
the other two this one burned burned
girop wow I probably butchered that name
uh and then Vanessa van Edwards okay and
then same thing
and the more
they're related to you the more options
it will be and there may not be anything
that you can pull from but you just sort
each one
and this gives us a starting point for
ideas six signs she wants you
laughs
okay Terry are we making all right that
was a good laugh though I like that one
we're probably not making that video but
you never know so 10 tricks to get her
to like you okay you know and a lot of
these look like book reviews uh so this
could be you know where Pablo comes in
you know with his book reviews and the
videos that he likes he likes doing it
um but yeah so there may not be a lot
here that we can pull from but a lot of
these videos have done well
but could could Terry take that six
signs she wants you
and and as soon they come in it says
um women women loves a man who's a
leader and then
transition on his his three or four ways
to become the leader and what you you
follow me yeah so so there's two things
to that the first is
how ethical does like how how connected
does Terry feel to the message so it's
still got to be hard first and then you
wrap your brain around it right so if
it's just a strategy then if it's too
much of a stretch outside what you do
don't do it just because it's a good
topic okay otherwise you're going to end
up hating your channel and hating the
work that you're doing because you're
you're stretching like could you apply
leadership to anything yes can you apply
confidence to anything yes of course
right but is that what you if Terry then
just goes and makes all of these kinds
of videos is he losing his soul
you know because it's just not fun to
make and the second part of that is are
you bringing in the right people so
ultimately what does Terry want to sell
you know if he if he wants to sell
leadership training and coaching
services for example making a video six
signs she wants you is is probably
targeting you know 13 14 16 18 22 year
old guys and uh they're probably not
going to be anywhere close to buying so
unless he's playing a really long game
and this is like a 15-year play for
Terry and just really thinking ahead of
the curve then it's probably not the
best fit and just move on to other
topics
solo videos
the most important thing is to lead with
a powerful opinion
and the question I always ask people is
what do you believe that others don't
so you're going to make a video on
habits great what do you believe about
habits that other people don't that they
would find weird like I can't believe
you said that
because this is our goal is to hook
somebody in
this is specific for Thought leadership
videos you are a thought leader you are
an expert you know things that other
people don't know that's the whole idea
why am I watching you because you're
going to teach me something so what do
you believe that I don't already know
and that's the first thing that comes
out of your mouth
so you know I've done when I've done my
thought Leadership Academy we'll spend
half a day just working on this stuff
practicing it like writing it down and
then saying it to the camera because
it's really hard
a lot of times it's hard to get out of
our own heads and so imagine what I find
helpful is imagining somebody imagine
one of your clients so Stephen might
imagine an entrepreneur Robert Robert or
his wife might be imagining somebody
who's you know dealing with trauma like
you picture somebody
and then that's the first thing you're
talking to this person
I would always picture this photographer
friend that I knew who always seemed to
struggle could never seem to figure it
out and instead of talking to the camera
like I'm talking to I'm talking to this
guy I'm talking to you
how would he react
um when I had my cameraman uh there was
one of them that uh
always seemed to kind of disagree with
what I said
at the beginning and it's like great
you're perfect so I pitched my first
sentence to him and then I see what his
reaction was and then that would that
would change how it would then pitch my
next sentence right it was like wait
what like perfect they got my first
sentence if you agree with me it's like
okay no I gotta I gotta I gotta change
it up so lead with a powerful opinion
the first thing out of your mouth this
is really hard because again A lot of
times people click record and then they
go back the default to how they've done
it hey welcome back it's Evan like no I
just told you don't do that powerful
opinion first thing out of your mouth
that's that's how we need to lead this
session
um so most important part uh deliver it
with with uh with power as well
so this is where a lot of thought
leaders also struggle is that okay you
finally get the perfect sentence out
but it's not delivered with any
enthusiasm or excitement and this is
from some top people as well who I know
are great speakers they're trying to
memorize that first sentence and then
when they say it the words come out
perfect but there's no emotional
commitment to it
you have to be emotionally connected to
the thing that you're saying as if
somebody is in front of you right now
and they're struggling with that very
thing and they need to hear from you I
know sometimes that's hard just talking
to a camera in studio and you're trying
to stress out about memorizing that
first line Etc but your your
um your stage presence really really
matters for anybody who's done speaking
you can get up on stage and say the
exact same words but if you don't have
stage presence you don't believe what
you're saying at the core of your being
you're not going to sway the audience
it's the exact same thing when you're
talking to a camera you're just talking
to you're talking to a bigger stage than
you would at any other stage but you
don't see them and so that makes it a
little more challenging so whether you
can call yourself out on it or if you've
got somebody on your team who's filming
with you who can say
hey uh that wasn't very good do it again
I remember when I recorded my audiobook
for for both built the server in year
one word I had two people in my ear my
producer who's looking at all the
technical stuff of like oh you know your
stomach rumbled or something
that again and then I had another
producer who was in LA who was more
paying attention to the tone
like hey Evan you read it perfectly but
there was no energy there like okay
thank you man do it again and I just
pick up from that line so the emotional
commitment like are you actually feeling
the words that you're saying as opposed
to just saying the words really really
really really matters once you get into
the teaching you'll be fine
I I very rarely meet somebody who signs
up for this program or other thought
leader experts trainers coaches I'm not
here to teach you how to teach for the
most part you guys do that great once
you get into the teaching you're fine
and you see that in the retention curves
like people are watching it's just that
beginning part and if we don't hook them
in at the beginning they're not going to
watch the rest of our teaching so
powerful opinion first sentence second
sentence is context sentence like what
did you just say you just told me
something that doesn't make sense to me
you told me something that's challenging
one of my belief systems
so repeat it again in different words
make it make a little bit more sense and
then raise the stakes and raise the
stake says what happens to me if I don't
change this thing about myself if I
don't if I don't make this change by
watching this video this video is going
to teach you something that's going to
change my life I'm going to become a new
person at the end of this video right
that's the that's at least your
emotional state going in that's why
we're making this video to shift
somebody's belief system on something
that you know about
if I don't make that shift in this video
what happens
what happens to me if I stay stuck what
happens to me
your job as a thought leader is to give
perspective
it's not just this one-off little moment
that I'm struggling it's my entire life
and so that's your job is this one
little thing that people think they care
about they need to they need to have a
much broader view of how this is
impacting every area of their life and
if you fix that it becomes uh the
Cornerstone Habit to change everything
in your life right it's like oh my God I
thought I was just searching for a video
now I'm watching this person who's about
to change my whole life right so that's
that becomes your job
so powerful opinion context sentence
raise the stakes if you have to write
those down
those three sentences if you have to
record it 30 times until you get the
energy and the flow right it's worth it
because once you get through this and
you get into the teaching you'll be fine
I don't need you to do another take when
you're 20 minutes in and you're on point
number two of whatever your your
teaching is going to be but if you don't
nail the first three sentences film it
again and film it again and film it
again until until it you got the words
right and most importantly you got the
heart right
so uh here's Anna who uh a member of the
channel I don't I don't see her today
but Robert her husband is here on on the
stream so uh Robert can be taking notes
uh this is one of her videos trauma
bonding explained and YouTube has added
something relatively new for cards on
these um retention curves so if you ever
see an eye here you can click over and
it'll show you what's going on so she's
got three intro continue segment and dip
uh intro is going to be here in that
blue section continue segment is
probably going to be here and then the
dip is going to be at the end it'll give
you some date on it we're not super
focused on these other two segments
we're focused on what happens at the
beginning so if you hover over the eye
on this one it says 81 percent of
viewers were still watching at the 30
second mark this is higher than typical
compared to your other other recent
videos nicely done hey hey good job good
job Robert you guys are doing it
uh so we're looking at this video right
it's a 13 minute video trauma bonding
explained and I pulled okay well what is
she doing you know what what's happening
why is it so good so at the 118 Mark
she's still at 73 percent
118 into the video she's still at 73 so
this is a great video how does she start
the video
there's one kind of romantic
relationship that I wouldn't wish on
anyone and that's the kind that's been
made intense by a Chama Bond if you are
abused or neglected as a kid you've
probably been through it and I want to
help you make sure it never happens
again
right Robert's smiling hey she's doing a
good job she's doing a good job Robert
give her give her some props uh this is
great I mean it's four sentences instead
of three but it's still great so you
know we have a powerful opinion context
sentence raising mistakes
the only thing I would uh swap out here
is probably
it was one critique on here I would not
use the word probably at the beginning
of every video you don't want to hedge
this if you were abused or neglected as
a kid you've been through this
and if there is a hedge then you address
it later but we don't address the Hedge
at the beginning
and that's where you know van were here
to ask her well okay how many people
who've been neglected and abused as the
kid have not been through
this trauma
right it's probably some really low
percent
so don't hedge but everything else is
great and so she leads to the powerful
opinion she's hitting 73 at 118 into the
video uh YouTube's giving her props for
having such a great intro on it
and look how well the video is doing
right so this video is just over a month
old 40 whatever 43 days let's call it 20
000 views which is 5.5
000 more than usual
so the gray line is what a usual video
would do and here's how this video is
doing
so all in great job you know and then I
used to start her videos with with
something else it used to be hey I'm
Anna I'm the crappy childhood fairy on
and on and on she switched it to
powerful opinion and it's working
if you like sharing the success stories
as well
now I also pulled an old video from the
channel that didn't have uh the the
powerful intro and this one is about
meditation so one I mean the thumbnail
isn't as good uh you know it's an older
video so Robert we can go back and work
on that one uh but look what happens at
the beginning
you know just tanks why well look at
what's happening on this video it's the
typical
uh logo with music copy childhood fairy
right and boom instantly tanks
right so now this also this video also
talks about meditation that's the
promise how to meditate twice a day
something
um The Meditation doesn't actually start
until here
so this is where we need to match the
thumbnail and the title and the
beginning of the video because people
are skipping ahead to get to here
because they don't want to see on any of
this intro or uh then Anna starts
talking about meditation Etc this is
what I mean this is a 24 minute video so
this is at least three four minutes into
the video
five minutes maybe
um before something actually happens
that delivers on the promise so when you
see a curve that drops this drastically
there's something wrong with our intro
right so now we can't go back and fix
this
um but going forward it's a great
example of what is working and what is
not working for the channel
this is a fun topic this is something
that I obsess over how do we get our one
minute audience retention it's it's a
super geeky topic of all the things that
um
that I
try to teach when I'm doing
presentations uh this is the only thing
that I get technical with the audience
retention curve the audience retention
curve the audience retention curve like
remember this thing pay attention to it
look at your data because it's easy to
get lost in YouTube data but this one is
super super important understand that
YouTube's goal is to keep you on YouTube
right that's their goal so the more
you're keeping people on YouTube the
more they're going to promote your
videos and so many people focus on
the entire video which is important but
what often happens is if you get the
first minute down really well and you're
keeping people for for that attention
they'll watch the rest of the video If
you go look at most of your curves you
you'll see it's mostly flat or just
slowly sloping down but that first mint
is where we tend to lose people so
people are often shocked if you go look
at your own stats people are often
shocked at how poorly their videos are
doing in that first minute so today
that's what we are talking about let me
share my screen boom specific strategies
that boost viewer retention I'm excited
okay let's dive in so the goal
the goal is 70 at one minute this is uh
this is a really hard number to hit
especially consistently nobody hits this
number consistently not not inside
thought leadership I don't do it nobody
that I've looked at does it
um
it's really really really really hard
and I've looked at everybody's Channel
at least the big Channel since I thought
leadership but it's still the goal it's
still still that elusive here's what
we're working towards and this curve
that's the audience attention curve
you'll see this on every single video
this is free inside YouTube Studio
product uh you can get lost again in
data but this one is super super super
important and it'll show you basically
where people are falling off so wherever
you know here whatever happened here
that sucks then that was good then that
sucks and then that sucked at the end
and then these little Peaks here this is
what we're going to share to social
content right we've talked about this in
the past but uh just quick refresh
this slide is one of you guys may have
seen in the past one minute retention
this video we did had 73 at one minute
has almost three million views on the
channel and this is what a typical Curve
will look like right it should be slowly
just declining over time and it's this
part that we're really trying to
optimize in this first minute trying to
make sure that we're keeping it not that
big a slump so you'll always get this
you'll always get this little drop here
at the beginning the key is not making
that drop and losing 40 of our audience
which happens to a lot a lot a lot a lot
a lot of channels
so here's something that we haven't
talked about yet that I wanted to just
bring up on your radar tubebuddy has a
tool that I requested uh and help them
build called the retention analyzer now
it's a little buggy and they don't
update it very often because they
basically made it for me and and some of
the people who like using it
um but it's not part of their core thing
that like everybody's using it for but
if you are using tubebuddy for split
testing right now
two buddies of tool that we use we've
done over 10 000 split tests on the
channel thumbnails titles Etc
if you're on that program you're on that
package I think that's 50 bucks a month
something like that it's not it's not
crazy expensive they have something
built in here as well called retention
analyzer
so if you go to your tubebuddy you click
on data and insights on the left and
then scroll down to retention analyzer
it'll pull up your most recent it's not
all it says all videos it's not it's
going to be your most recent I think 50
videos and then you can sort by
retention at various time stamps so I'd
say with sort by the one minute Mark and
see where you're at and you can just get
a sense of how well you're doing which
videos are performing well which videos
aren't uh just to give you a sense you
know instead of having to Go videos one
by one by one by one by one this will
help you give get an over overall sense
and see where you're doing well and
which videos uh are not doing so well
and we need to make a few adjustments to
help your channel grow so I would
definitely check that out if you're if
you're on the package for the split
testing you're already paying for this
anyway so you might as well take a look
and see which videos are performing well
and where there's some room for
improvement okay so today we're going to
talk about a lot of the dues but before
that I want to talk about some of the
don't do so this is the things you want
to avoid when you're starting your video
okay these will these will destroy your
audience retention curve
intros hi I'm Evan and I XYZ right no
intros live stream welcomes are the
worst you know a live stream
the first couple minutes usually really
really really suck on the live stream
you're welcoming people you're saying hi
you're asking about their day that's
great for a live stream environment but
not great for a YouTube video again
we're trying to assume the people who
are watching our videos don't know who
we are that's our target audience we're
not talking to our subscribers we're
talking to our non-subscribers this is
the first time they're seeing you so we
want to hit them with something that's
going to be really powerful don't do a
Sizzle reel
you getting out of your car looking
fancy or on stage looking like a special
person like none of that stuff really
brings in a lot of attention uh call to
actions we don't want call to action at
the beginning because we lose people
you'll see a big drop in your honest
attention curve
um and then Audio Only Audio Only is
really hard we're I'm working on a
couple strategies actually with some
podcasters like how do I turn my podcast
into a YouTube video when I don't have
video when it's just an audio stream and
every time I've seen it it's really
tanked but if you can make it visually
appealing I think there's a case I think
there just hasn't been a lot of
innovation on the podcast inside for how
you can play with visuals so these are
all the don't Do's don't do any of these
things and if you're looking at your
data and you're seeing that you're
you're at you know 40 retention at one
minute you're probably doing one or
multiple of these and it's not helping
your videos grow
okay so we just finished uh
a breakdown of 990 of our videos this
just happened on Tuesday so what day is
today Thursday so two days ago I haven't
even gone through all the data myself
yet but uh I had one of my guy my I have
a full-time data analyst on my team and
that's what he does is goes and looks
store data and gives us suggestions on
what's working what's not working and
you compiled this giant spreadsheet of
of which videos are popping hard you
know we're at 78 retention at one minute
in which ones
are underperforming and so I'm going to
share with you some of the insights that
we found today which I'm excited because
I didn't even know some of these things
until Tuesday
um having a full-time data analyst
really really helps
uh so I'm excited let's dive in and look
at some of the some of the data Okay so
that first minute again our goal is to
capture attention so multiple camera
angles we found really really has been
helping and this is some of the stuff
that I used to do that I haven't done as
much it's it's shocking when you look at
your data you might find oh something I
was doing back in 2019 is actually
outperforming what I'm doing right now
and all of these numbers are for the
past 90 days on my channel so it's not
lifetime of video this worked I've been
around for 12 years or something so it's
not like this worked back in 2014 and it
doesn't work anymore all the stats is
basically the last 90 days so multiple
camera angles we did four transitions in
the first 15 seconds and that helped
lead to 78 at one minute
okay getting outside
switching up the background having some
color
again this one four transitions in 18
seconds 70 at one minute
so I'm seriously looking at okay what
what can we do besides just using I love
my studio but besides just using the
studio what else could we use where else
could we go now some of this requires
more editing this one is pretty simple
this one even if you're doing it
yourself you could just do different
camera angles
for the intro this is only for the first
minute don't worry about making it
highly produced
um I
value editing but I think ultimately
it's going to be your capabilities to
pull out great information it's going to
carry the day but in that first minute
especially the editing can can make a
difference to hook somebody's attention
so you could do this even if you're
filming on your own but if you have
somebody as a camera operator helping
you you can move the side move around
just have different angles and again
just getting outside if you can if it's
warm we got summer you know right here
so can you do anything outside uh to
just shake up the background just to
make it a little more interesting a
little more appealing
um one hack that Billy Jean loves doing
for his ads if you don't know Billie
Jean he's one of the the experts on on
advertisements so YouTube ads Facebook
ads Etc is go look up in your city what
are the top places that people like to
go to
and then try to film there
so it takes more time uh it takes more
budget it takes it takes a team to maybe
help you but if there's an interesting
background so I'm in Toronto there's you
know the CN tower there's Niagara Falls
there's you know different places but if
you look at the top places people like
to visit and then that happens to be in
your background that could help just get
people interested at the beginning
Fast Cuts so
here's an example where we did 10
transitions in 21 seconds
where we're doing a preview of things to
come and this is something that after
looking at the data on this we're going
to be playing with it instead of longer
clips
doing coming up leading with shorter
Clips but more of them as opposed to
longer more in-depth Clips really that
first minute is people are justifying
their time with you
I don't know who you are I like the
topic do I want to watch this video you
know it's like people will skim an
article before they read it that's
what's happening right now so if you can
give them a chance to skim the video
before they watch it you can hook them
in so this is something when we plan a
lot more with uh we're after seeing this
I just instructed my team hey I want our
next two weeks of videos on the top 10
Channel I want to be doing 10 cuts for
each one and let's see if we can play
this out so think about your own videos
think about your own content uh you
don't have to have 10 rules
but how can you take some of the
Highlight moments and instead of just
one or two highlight moments go for five
six seven eight highlight moments that
are in more in Rapid succession to say
okay there's a lot there's a lot of meat
coming up in this video
I want to watch it
so this this was really mind-blowing for
me this was some experiment we did I
don't know back in 2016 just as a as a
one-off and never went back to it for
whatever reason
like wait a minute that actually worked
let's go back and look at it and you
know when you have 10 000 videos like I
do on my channel uh there's a lot of
data to report to to get some
interesting information so super fast
Cuts I would definitely play with some
of these for your videos
series analytics this is where when you
have some kind of consistent content you
can start to look at what kinds of
videos are performing well versus not so
series examples could be you're going to
do a talking head video you're going to
do a coaching video you're going to do a
demonstration video you're going to do a
one-on-one with a client video you're
gonna do a reaction video you're gonna
do a how-to video You're Gonna Do a
video from uh the stage you're gonna do
a big Zoom call video like you're
playing with different ideas
so that you can start to see which ones
are working out if you're up if you're
starting to work towards a Content
calendar and you're moving from the once
a week to three to seven don't do the
same kind of video on repeat
don't just stick to one format start to
play with different types different
content styles that that feel right for
you for example I don't do reaction
videos
um I find a lot of the reaction videos
are are kind of negative it's like I
can't believe you just said that oh my
God what an idiot like I don't like
putting that energy out so I don't I
don't I don't like reaction videos
there's no reaction videos the only
reaction video I've ever done is me
reacting to my first video and I watched
it back and was mostly embarrassed and
laughing at myself for how bad it was
um but for some of you maybe that's
maybe that is what would work super well
um so it's got to be it's got to feel
right it's got to be authentic but if
you're if you're getting to multiple
times a week make sure that you're
having different kinds of Series so you
can start
um seeing the data and seeing what's
working what's not
this is kind of a messy graph so I'm
going to explain it this is what I go
through with my team
every month
um and this is this is some old data but
I pulled it up just to show you as an
example
this we use for every series on the
channel so I just pulled three out for
you guys to look at this is a top 10
Series this is my top 50 Series and this
is the espresso which is a morning
Series so this is us doing you know top
10 and over between free top 50 at Oprah
Winfrey espresso is more me talking so
be uh a clip and then I'm talking about
it and then this goes on so we have each
color is a different channel so these
are just two channels and then there's a
green Channel and then red and orange
and this is some giant sheet that I
didn't want to overwhelm you guys with
but what this basically looks at and and
um I've been on my team he he pulls this
together for me once a month and we have
a call once a month to go over it is
we're looking at watch time
for the past month of videos and then
how many subscribers we gain per video
so what these two numbers mean is
if we were making our data uh what month
is it now we're in May okay so for June
when we have our meeting this number is
going to reflect how well how many watch
hours did we get
per video on average in this series for
two months back so the videos that
launched in April
one month of data being collected
and then
we talk about it in June
the reason why we do it like that is uh
a channel that like mine has been around
for so long
a lot of the data a top 10 video from
2016 isn't relevant anymore to what's
happening right now
so I care about the new videos that are
coming up and how well they've done in
their first four to six weeks
so
the April videos
are contained so there might be let's
say there's 10 April videos in the top
10 Series so those 10 videos that
launched in April and if you guys have
questions pop it in the chat because
this this part might be a little
confusing so I'm happy to answer and go
deeper on it but if we release 10 top 10
videos in April
in June we then go back and look at all
the data
and say okay our top 10 videos got us on
average
389
000 watch hours and each video got us on
average 79 new subscribers between
launch date and June
between April and June now these will go
on to continue to do super well but
we're tracking what happened in the
first four to six weeks of each video
uh so what this helps us do is start to
analyze okay which series do we keep
going with and which series do we cut
so you know we uh we we did all these
top tens and I wanted to show this this
data is probably
2017 2016 data
um but we've kept this going you know if
I look to show you my recent ones should
that the newer stuff
this is where we did our first top 50 to
say Hey what if we launch a new series
top 50.
let's just go super long on a video
so you can see our top tens we're doing
122 000 watch hours and 16 subscribers
per video in that month we did a top 50
and look at the jump it went from it
went to 600 000 watch hours and 61
subscribers per video
the next month did Super well the next
month didn't do so well we lost
subscribers and only 120 000 watch hours
so we're constantly comparing these
numbers and you can look at it across
Series so if we look at it this month
here
you can see okay so the top 10 got got
six figures watch time 17 subscribers
top 50 crushed it on both and the
espresso got 51 000 about half the watch
hours of this but double the subscribers
and so we're constantly playing with the
series to see which ones are doing well
then inside each one you can dive in to
see well which which video did well for
us inside here
you know so if these are 10 videos which
of them did Super well and which ones
didn't to give us more information but
this for you could be you know coaching
Series this could be again all the
different options direct the camera
reaction
Etc and you start to pay attention to
how many watch hours did I get from
these videos and how many subscribers
did I gain from these videos if you
wanted to add the third column of
Revenue you could too revenue is
typically more topic driven though
then series driven
um but if that's really really important
to you we don't track Revenue as a as
the main metric for our YouTube videos
um we care mostly about growth so
Drew's got his hand up what where what
he got Drew so I'm just trying to make
sure I understand so each row represents
a single month
of that series having been released yes
yes yeah so this would be June July
August September you know October and so
on
so when collecting that data so I'm
assuming this is like on one
page and then on another page you have
each individual video the total
cumulative and then that number just
simply reflects the sum of all of the
videos that were released that month
yeah so if again if this was June it'd
be the sum of all the videos
from April that were released
and then divided by how many videos are
released so this is an average this is
per video oh oh okay okay yeah because
we'll do
you know we'll end up doing 22 top tens
in a month but only one top 50 as an
example
so to add them all up it doesn't make
sense you have to then give me on a per
video basis I don't think you have to go
this deep even just I I'm obsessed with
this stuff so I've shown this to other
big YouTubers like nobody tracks it as
detailed as you guys do
um so you don't have to go to this level
I'm just showing you the idea is I want
you to start thinking about on a series
level so we looked at Channel which is
great but that's
to Ashley's question about how do we
make strategic decisions that's hard
when you're just looking at total views
and total revenue
um total subscribers Etc once you get to
a series by series level it starts to
educate us to say hey these ones are
doing better than others so if I look at
this line and just a one-off month what
usually do it for at least three months
to see
a one-off month isn't enough
typically so but this month like the top
50 looks like a a runaway winner and the
next month it's also looking doing
really well on the watch hours not as
well on the subscribers compared and
then next month whatever we did here
sucked right we lost 21 subscribers so I
don't know who we profiled or what that
video was now again all these videos
will still end up winning long term
this is first four to six weeks
and why four to six weeks is because
that's usually how long it takes for
suggested to start to kick in
you might have a crazy runaway winner
that suggests it starts to pop you know
within the first week but for the most
part for most videos
you give that four to six week window
usually after 30 day Mark you start to
see suggested views go up if the video
is going to do well if you still don't
see any suggested views after 30 or 60
days that video is probably dead
um so it could be worth doing a redo on
the thumbnail title or just the video
you know itself wasn't very good
so this is how every month every month
since 2015 uh I've met with my guy Ivan
and we go over this and we make
decisions afterwards from this and this
sheet this is only three columns this
sheet is maybe 20 columns long for all
of our series
and we'll just dive into each one and
say okay okay this one this one's not
looking so good what do we need to do to
fix it
and the goal is always to try to pull
out the always have one test series that
we're trying to beat
the rest of our content to make it back
in
so if you're if you're making three
videos a week as an example you have
your two that you know are consistent
winners and then you have your one
that's a test so maybe you're trying a
book review or maybe you're trying a
role player maybe you're trying uh a
coaching call you're trying something
for four weeks to just to see how well
are we doing and you're always trying to
beat the winner
video analytics is on a on an individual
video level how well are we doing what
data do I look at what are the important
things to pay attention to
uh so The Impressions and click-through
rate are super super super super super
important
you can get lost in data on individual
videos but this is one of the most
important things to pay attention to so
if you go to your channel you click on
analytics on the side
and then you look at uh the Impressions
you get on the videos I usually like
going 90 days again so it's what's most
relevant right now what's popping
and then we're looking at our
click-through rate that's what this
means here impression click through
right
and people when they ask me what's a
good click-through rate
it's a it's a logical question asked but
it's not a great question
because
click-through rate is relative
so
here's what happens if you have a really
high click-through rate on your video
and the video is doing well it's got
good retention on your video YouTube's
going to recommend it to more people who
don't know who we are
which is good that's that's a great
thing to have happen but the more
YouTube recommends our videos to people
who don't know us
our click-through rate is going to drop
because it's more and more and more of a
colder audience
so if your video comes out if if Ash is
finally launches a new video to having
solution you know it's going to be great
we're all going to cheer and celebrate
so when that that video comes out
chances are you know the people who
these 113 000 subscribers who follow
tapping solution her channel uh are
probably gonna really like the video
they're like oh my God new videos is
great
and if that video starts doing well it's
now going to reach out to more and more
people who have never heard of the
typing solution who don't even know
what's happening is and that's the
ultimate goal because our goal is not
just to talk to people who already know
who we are our goal is to talk to people
who have no idea who we are and that's
the power of YouTube but as we start
branching out if if Ashley is making a
video on tapping if it's going to
tapping people they're going to have a
high click-through rate right they know
what it is they like it if it's going to
people have no idea who what's happening
is the click through rate is going to
drop
so a low click-through rate is not
necessarily a bad thing if it's reaching
a broad audience
so a good click-through rate is relative
to how many Impressions you're getting
on the video
it's relative to how your other videos
are doing
so
for example if I see a video that has
um a 12 a 12 click-through rate
that's actually not grid that's not good
because it means YouTube is not
recommending your video to enough new
people
you're only talking to your current
audience that means there's probably
something wrong with the video itself
you did a great job on your thumbnail
and title to get people to click but the
video itself kind of sucks
nobody's actually watching it so YouTube
doesn't want to recommend it to more
people
so this is why this graph is so
important whenever I'm looking at doing
split testing on my channel and or
looking at other people's channels as
well
if you sort by how many Impressions you
have so these are all different videos
with different Impressions then you can
look at the relative
click-through rate
so the channel average for those 90 days
was four percent
and then these are the ones that I want
to fix like two percent 2.1 2.6
uh 2.8 so anything in the twos on here
now if my number one video was two
percent I'm not worried about that
but if this video has 160 000
Impressions look at these two videos 160
000 I'm sorry 161 million
I can't read 161 million impressions on
this video
156 million impressions on the pretty
close right almost the same what's five
million impressions they're pretty close
here at the top
five percent click-through rate two
percent click-through rate
so this video got double the views more
than double the views of this video off
the same number of impressions
so this thumbnail has to be fixed this
thumbnail title combination has to be
fixed
and so that's what you do you keep
looking in different impression bands
and you start to see
if I'm looking at you know the if I look
in the 40 000 here so 42 to 48 the best
one here is 3.3 percent
these ones are underperforming so I want
to go in and fix all of these ones
why it's so important is even just
looking at these two as an example
YouTube is recommending the videos to
people
it's giving us impressions
people aren't clicking
this is the problem with how we're
presenting our video
YouTube thinks our video is good that's
why we're getting the impressions
but people aren't clicking so our cover
sucks
right and this isn't a subjective like I
work so hard on that thumbnail how could
people not like it okay well they don't
like it you know fix it
it's it's not being I like making data
driven decisions so even though I pour
this has been thumbnails that I just
pour my heart and soul into or titles
that I just feel are just epic and
amazing I'm so proud of myself and then
you know 2.1 click through okay perfect
that one sucked let's go next and keep
testing keep trying but this gives you
Direction on a per video level where to
go and start making changes and updates
and this is why YouTube is so powerful
is that you can go back and fix this
stuff
where Facebook Instagram Twitter
whatever you're not going back and
updating this video might be eight years
old I could still go back and update
Ramsay media has got his hand up you got
something quick
hey Evan can you just provide a little
more context for us about earlier you
said if your number one video is in the
high twos you're not worried about it
and I and I and given what you're saying
about the other stuff I'm like but why
like like why wouldn't you still want to
raise that click-through rate
yeah
I'm not worried about it because it's
reaching a big wide audience so if
you're doing your hypnosis videos and
you're talking to hypnosis people
they're gonna they're gonna love it
but if you're reaching
say your video shows up against my
audience
a bunch of entrepreneurs
most people are probably familiar with
the term hypnosis but maybe haven't
watched a video or don't know how it
works so if you're if you're branching
out like the fact that these numbers are
close means that this one has to be
fixed but if this one often the number
one video might have
you know way higher so in this world
maybe it has a billion Impressions and
compared to 161. it doesn't mean that
you can't go back and continue to try to
improve it I keep working on my top
videos as well to try to make them
better
but it just means that it's not a bad
number I I would expect the top video on
your channel to have the lowest
click-through rate
it's very typical
so this one just massively over
performed here at the five percent it's
very rare to have I gotta look at what
this video is because it's very rare to
have your number one video be better
than your channel average
this would be if you if we remove this
first one this is what this would be
what I would expect 2.1 2.6 3.5 3.7 3.54
and then we start getting the higher
numbers as we start to go down
if you have a giant Gap between number
one and number two or number one two
three four five like if you look at your
own data and pull it up don't freak out
if if your number one video is two
percent
it means it's reaching a new audience so
it's good
it doesn't mean that you still can't
improve it but it doesn't mean that it's
a bad click-through rate oh my God why
does this one suck so much
the next thing that we look at is
audience retention at one minute
so on a per video basis this is another
thing that I'm obsessed over so every
video we've gone through this I've
shared some examples we've done Channel
breakdowns but if you're looking at how
to fix your individual videos It's a
combination of
the click-through rate which is title
and thumbnail and then also the
retention how much are people actually
sticking so if you had a 12
click-through rate video
uh I'm expecting this curve to look
really bad the one minute retention is
probably going to be really poor you
didn't keep people
so what I'm obsessed with was trying to
hit the 70 at one minute that's that's
virtually impossible to do consistently
but it's a high high Mark so you want to
be a good starting point is 50 at one
minute and then working our way up 60 is
a really good number 70 is insane gold
standard try to hit that and when you're
looking at your curve this basically
just shows where people are falling off
so you know this first whatever we this
is a 13 minute video so this part sucks
and then it goes up so especially when
you see it go up like that wow this part
really sucks we should cut that you know
for future videos don't don't do that
stuff again and then it's okay and then
there's this you know slow curve this is
what it we want it to look like these
Peaks here this is what we cut for
Instagram and Twitter is the highest
engagement moment so we're cutting that
out free social content and this is what
I'm still doing now guys I mean I'm
helping Brendan burchard launch three
um YouTube channels around his growth
day product so we joint ventured on them
and every week my team is pulling
together a list of clips
based off of this so when the curve goes
up Brendan here's the clips for social
media for this week and then his team
Cuts them together you know from here to
here so for this video I'd probably go
you know this is a short little
Instagram reel here and then from here
to here is an Instagram video
or Tick Tock video
right and so the data just shows us what
people are liking
so it one it tells us how to fix our
videos right this really sucks don't do
that again the ending sucks as well look
how many people we lost at the end don't
do that again
flat lines are great slow curves are
good and any increases we're cutting for
social and also looking what happened
did I say something great
um did a CAT walk in the background you
know like what happened then that made
people really want to watch this part
and then try to do more of that
uh so on a per video basis click-through
rate and then one minute audit retention
we really really really pay a lot of
attention to if you want to see this
full video as well as trained live with
me twice a month to blow up your brand
join the brand Linux training program
there's a link to join right there next
to me continue to believe I'll see you
there